[Música]
todo parece apacible en el valle de suat
Sin embargo desde hace varios meses el
terror se entrometió en la que se conoce
como la suiza de Pakistán la violencia
explotó sus autores el ttp el theric
talibán Pakistán un grupo armado talibán
pakistaní responsable de numerosos
ataques y varios asesinatos dirigidos el
padre de Este joven hombre es una de sus
víctimas su identidad se mantiene en
secreto por razones de seguridad volvía
a la mezquita tras el rezo de la noche
en el camino había grandes espigas de
maíz a ambos lados ahí donde ve trigo y
los terroristas escondían detrás le
dispararon fue herido en la cabeza y los
brazos su padre fue asesinado en
septiembre de 2022
era miembro del comité para la paz y
estaba en contacto con las autoridades
locales y el ejército para promover la
paz en la región al día siguiente de su
asesinato los talibanes declararon que
lo habían asesinado porque era miembro
del comité la razón es que quieren que
las personas no estén en contacto con
las autoridades encargadas de hacer
respetar la ley y que dejen de entregar
la información al ejército los talibanes
reinaron en el valle de Swat entre 2007
y 2009 año durante el cual el ejército
lo sacó de ahí enardecidos por la toma
del poder por los talibanes en
Afganistán hace 17 meses intentaron un
resurgimiento Quienes no los apoyan son
percibidos como traidores es el caso de
Abdul rajín este representante de los
comerciantes locales ya no puede
desplazarse sin sus tres guardaespaldas
hoy se reúne con vendedores del bazar la
situación se volvió mala para ustedes de
que los talibanes regresaron a la región
desde hace varios meses Abdul recibe
decenas de amenazas este mensaje dice
usted no respondió a mi último mensaje
todas las personas influyentes están en
contacto con nosotros y nosotros
perdonamos a la mayoría usted no vivirá
en paz mientras sea enemigo de los
talibanes su exigencia Es que mi
responsabilidad como musulmán según
ellos sea ayudarlos financieramente me
ordenan como responsable del sindicato
de los comerciantes recolectar 3.000
rupias con cada almacén aquí y
enviárselas una tarea que rechaza así
ponga en riesgo su vida
A mi parecer no menos de 300
comerciantes de mingora Fueron abordados
por los talibanes para extorsionarlos
cuentan con un sistema sofisticado le
envían a las personas informaciones
personales
les dan detalles sobre sus hijos las
escuelas que frecuentan y los amenazan
con secuestrarlos a ellos y a sus hijos
Si no les dan el dinero algunos de los
comerciantes se dieron
tres numerosos ataques a la fuerza
pública y a los civiles decenas de miles
de personas salieron a las calles del
Valle para protestar contra la violencia
el pasado mes de octubre entre los
organizadores está el anp un partido
político progresista Kawaii es el
secretario general en el Valle del Swap
los habitantes de soat salieron a la
calle porque el gobierno pakistaní había
firmado un acuerdo de César fuego con
los talibanes Y estos últimos regresaron
a pesar de toda su
y empezaron de nuevo sin resurrección la
gente pensó que debíamos resistir a
dicho extremismo y protestar contra
ellos
luchar contra el terrorismo está más que
nunca en el centro de las discusiones
del partido
el terrorismo no afecta solamente al
individuo también destruyó el tejido
social
pone fin a la educación afecta a los
negocios la vida en su conjunto se
detiene
debemos prepararnos todos y hacerle
frente a esta amenaza terrorista y
resistir a ella mediante manifestaciones
pacíficas y elevando nuestra voz
el reino de los talibanes en la región
mayoritariamente pastún dejó rastros
indelebles cuando estaban en el poder
hicieron explotar las escuelas de
nuestros hijos
destruyeron todas las infraestructuras
cortaban cabezas de civiles y gritaban
eslogan Es sobre el islam diciendo que
todos los baston eran como estos
terroristas pero no es cierto los pastum
también son gente civilizada educada y
pacífica
[Música]
esta escuela primaria no cambió ninguno
de sus hábitos por ahora a pesar de la
inseguridad
hoy vamos a estudiar la vida de Joseph
quién era
cada uno sabe aquí de La amenaza que
representan los talibanes para la
educación
si los terroristas regresan la situación
Se volverá muy mala
las escuelas los colegas y los otros
establecimientos educativos tendrán que
cerrar
los padres temen enviar a sus hijos a la
escuela
la situación Se volverá Igualmente muy
difícil para las mujeres que no podrán
salir y permanecerán encerradas en casa
un escenario en curso en el Afganistán
vecino desde que los talibanes retomaron
el poder el 15 de agosto de 2021